let me speak to you because i'm i'm
speaking to you on brooke
soon yeah uh
i like him yeah so but that another
example
i was ask him to tell you a joke about
unrand
if he can do it so there
that's one criticism i've heard you say
which is they're unable to speak
to any weaknesses in either iran's or
objectivist
worldview yes that's really
uh you you put it i know you're half
joking but
that's actually a legitimate discussion
to have i'm not joking at all
because that's to me one of the
criticisms
and one of the explanations why the
world seems to uh disrespect ayn rand
the the people that do is she
kind of implies that her ideas are like
flawless
she says they correspond to reality yeah
right that's the term she uses
that i mean objective is it's in the
name
it's you know it's just facts like
it's impossible to basically argue
against because it's pretty simple
it's just all facts and that's it's
possible to argue against but she would
say
she's never met a good critic who can
argue the facts about misrepresentation
and she's not entirely wrong she's often
caricatured because she has a very
extreme personality and extreme
worldview but that to me i mean some
people there's a guy named in the
physics mathematics community called
stephen wolfram
i don't know if you're well from alpha
yeah okay he has a
similar style of speaking sometimes
which is like
i've created a science but that turns a
lot of people off like this kind of
weird
confidence but he's one of my favorite
people i think one of the most brilliant
people
if you just ignore that little bit of
ego
or whatever you call that yeah that are
some beautiful ideas in there
and that for me objectivism i'm
undereducated about it
about it uh i hope to be more educated
but there's some interesting ideas that
again just like with ufos uh
not that there's a connection don't
bring that up for your own he won't like
it
i'm runs like ufos oh no no no this
interview is over
that's that's a good yarn okay uh but
you know you have to be a little bit
open-minded
but what's your sense of of objectivism
what's
uh are there interesting ideas that are
useful
to you to think about i own her copy of
the first printing of the fountainhead
so that should tell you a little bit
about how my affection for miss rand
how heavy that goes um i iran
does not have all the answers but she
has all the questions so if you study
rand you are going to be forced to think
through some very basic things and
you're gonna have your eyes open very
very heavily
she was not perfect she never claimed to
be perfect she was asked on donahue
is it true that according to your
philosophy you're a perfect being
she said i never think of myself that
way and she said but if you ask me do i
practice what i preach the answer is yes
resoundingly um she's a fascinating
woman
uh what is really interesting about her
and this something you'd appreciate
personally is when you read her essays
she'll have these weird asides
and it looked like she was talking about
art and she'd be like and this is why
the u.s should be the only country with
nuclear weapons
and when you follow a brilliant mind
making these
seemingly disparate connections it's
something i find to be just absolutely
inspiring and awesome and entertaining
um i think there's lots of things about
her that people like yaran would make
uncomfortable um
well like she they so objectivism
like any other philosophy has all these
techniques to kind of
hand wave away things you don't want to
talk about and like pretend that so they
talk about things like having
no meta metaphysical significance right
so what that means is like well what
about this i don't talk about it like it
doesn't matter
like it literally means in fancy
philosophical terms doesn't matter
or they will say correctly that it's
very
twisted in our culture that when we have
heroes we look for their flaws instead
of looking for their virtues that's a
100 valid perspective
however if i'm sitting here telling you
that i think this woman is a badass and
she's amazing and she should be studied
but there's also these idiosyncrasies
they don't want to hear it
because they and i think it's very
convenient for them because there's a
lot of things she did
that work here's an example rand was
very very pro
a happiness and poor pleasure she was
very pro-sex
which is kind of surprising looking at
her and how she talked and how strident
she was
as a result of this she never got her
cats fixed to deny them the pleasure of
orgasm
so her male cats are spraying up her
entire house yeah
like that is i mean that's her putting
her philosophy into practice
but it's still gross yeah so that's the
kind of thing where
i don't think he'd another thing is rand
had an art an article
on a woman president and she said a
woman should never be president right
now when rand says things that are too
goofy for them they say
oh that's not objectivism that's her
personal preference it's like
she did not have these lines objectivism
was always defined as ein rand's
writings plus the additional essays in
her books
so if this was in part of those books
this counts as official objectivism but
they pretend
otherwise so that's another example plus
they they she
was and i bet you she was on the
spectrum to some extent i'm not joking
i'm not using that derisively
she was of the belief and not
inaccurately in it because
that humor is used to denigrate and
humiliate
and she was thinking about the jon
stewart type before there was a jon
stewart and a lot of times
like well how i use mocking but she was
resentful
correctly that a lot of times people who
are great and accomplished
little nobodies will make a punch line
uh just to bring them down and just
about here
here's an example i just thought of i
remember in i remember when it was must
be in the 90s
they had a segment on mtv of all these
musicians
who were making their own perfumes right
and this girl grabbed princess perfume
and before she even smelled it she had
the joke ready she just oh
this smells almost as bad as this music
lately it's like first of all i'm sure
the perfume is fine
yeah and second of all this is prince
he's one of the all-time greats and you
can't wait
to you know you know denigrate him like
and part i want to be like ryan like how
dare you
like as if as if this perfume in any way
in any way mitigates his amazing
accomplishments and achievements
you horrible person but i do have some
great iran jokes and he would not be
happy about them
the perfume thing the problem with is
just not funny not that
oh he sucks okay great not that
they dared to try to be humorous right
because i don't know why you mentioned
jonathan because john stewart's pretty
can be funny right but he taught a
generation
you still see this on twitter where
things have to be inherently sarcastic
and snide but isn't that i mean aren't
you practicing that no i use irony it's
not sarcasm here's an example when
people
like you say something and someone reply
to be like um last i checked blah blah
blah blah and i'll say that
i go what do you think saying last i
checked added to your point you're
giving me valuable information and data
but you are trained to believe that it
has to be couched
in this sneering it doesn't just give me
the information this is useful
information
yeah that's that's true it's a jerk but
see john stewart did it
masterfully correct and they don't and
they they don't it's it's like people
who copy community certain comedians
you try to copy them and you lose
everything in the process of copying
yeah
yeah yep okay uh
but in terms of the the philosophy of
you know selfishness this kind of
individual focused idea and i'm i
imagine
that connects with you yes and i think
it would connect with more people they
understood what she meant by nathaniel
brandon who was her heir until she kind
of broke with him and and
he was a co-dedicatee of atlas shrugged
said
no one will say ayn rand's views with a
straight face they won't say
i believe that my happiness matters and
is important and is worth fighting for
and that ayn rand says this then she's
dangerous now
it's very easy to say this could have
dangerous consequences if you're a
sociopath
but to put it in those terms uh i think
is extremely healthy i think more people
should want to be happy and and
have i think a lot of us are raised to
be apologetic especially in
this cynical media culture that if you
say i want to be happy i want to
love my life that it's just like okay
sweetheart and you
the eye rolling and i think that's so
pernicious and so horrifying and this is
why i'm a camus person
because camus thought the archenemy was
cynicism and i could not agree more
like if you're the kind of person if
someone likes a band and you're like oh
you like them blah blah it's like
this gives them happiness yeah now
there's certain exceptions but it gives
you happiness
it's not for you that's cool okay this
is beautiful
i i so agree with you on the eye rolling
but you see the best of trolling as not
the eye roll correct of course not the
best of trolling
is taking down the eye rollers
you